are you excited for the next game from
Saints Row developer volition well
they've announced the agents of ma'am is
coming this August and we recently got
to talk to them all about the hero
shooters open-world activities I'm Matt
and this GameSpot news update is ready
to take over some outposts volition told
us that some of the side activities you
can expect an agents of mayhem include
races outpost takeovers and Legion lairs
these are dungeons that you can stumble
upon while doing the main story or
exploring the world completing them
earns you rewards experience crafting
materials and money volition says that
players will be able to spend a lot of
time and agents of mayhem but the
experience will probably be a little
shorter than saints row for agents of
mayhem launches for ps4 Xbox one and PC
on August 15 the rest of our interview
goes more in depth on its connections to
Saints Row and the inspiration it draws
from the 1980s you can read the full
thing on GameSpot calm but if you want
to familiarize yourself with more of
this year's releases check out the
latest episode of the lobby where we
talk about our most anticipated games of
2017
[Music]